first one how does this house this
opponent again one of the great things
having put somewhere in here right I
think this is sufficiently that I mean
it's movie but like you can see where
these numbers are P from the question
and when I look at this this structure
that tells me that the person we've got
this number understood where it came
from
regardless of whether nothing medically
correct I haven't checked that yet
because I gave my secular this is
someone else okay can we just double
check like is it constructed properly 14
or twenty-eight what is that that is the
hourly rate so we're multiplying that by
everything and then what's in the
bracket represents what like what's how
would you give it title to everything in
the brackets
that's yeah that's kind of the
equivalent oh I say equivalent because
she doesn't work that actual amount of
hours but it's the equivalent of what
number else she's worked because there's
thirty five normally right then this
next eight hours counts for eight times
one and a half right so there's that
time the hop which I guess means 12 on
this to number where did that come from
okay so double time and then we get ten
because that's the weather
alright that's left over so this is good
because the ten actually is not given to
you in the question you kind of just
have to work that out
thirty five plus a of course brings you
up to forty three which means that 10 is
left over previously pulled out now
that's perfect to me so assuming that we
put that into our calculator correctly I
give that a big thumbs up okay happy
with that yes let's have a look at this
one so again the brackets so helpful
because they tell us about what they sit
down the different parts of the arm of
the actual number so what this part this
is the this is the Commission per se
and a percentage okay very important and
if you're going to go ahead and as this
is done why would you get them they
start if you're going to go ahead and
write five point a as in tricking the
question you absolutely absolutely must
include the percent sign right you don't
have to if you don't want to write the
percent but if you don't we've got to
write it as a decimal because you can't
write you certainly kind of write five
point eight times whatever you'll get
one of those answers where it's like
millions of dollars right so it's not
gonna watch out for that it's similar to
what I'm telling out what's this bit
what's this piece
Petain and that's the that's the
retainer and we've seen how many days
per week she works so that's where it
comes out who's coming today
okay now down here let's just actually
pieces together together
so weekly travel outs of fifteen dollars
to it yet
okay that's a great question when you
have a look right 5.8% Commission
what does commission apply to you and
the answer is it's how much you
soundbites how much you stow some some
senses this number has nothing to do
with the per day or the number of days
like had she sold the same amount of
stuff in a day she'd still make that
amount does that make sense so that's my
first six the six day never never comes
into play girl right because it's
independent on the amount of time you
spend good question
okay just lastly it's species up weekly
travel down to 50 20 years right so I
see that something's gonna work when on
weekly basis how many weeks are there
anything you two okay so I just I've got
some space around 52 now the first thing
that she gets is that travel out so
that's $50 20 and when we get out
18 okay so in this 1872 right happens
per hour so if I add on 1852 then it
stands to reason I started 7.17 yeah it
stands to reason that then I need to
know how many hours in hourly rate to
matches up with a number of hours okay
clearly running out of space over here
but we can work this out right how do I
do this okay four hours per weekday so
times four times five five degree days
in a week and then that's only one
week's pay right is that okay okay now
remember I started out with 52 right I
write that right at the front and then I
put brackets here so I guess remember
how we entitled this thing here the
title of these packets would be 10 or
number hours right over the course of
week I would title this total amount
earned over the course of the week so I
don't need to multiply this by 52 again
I've already done that
to relent here what do we how far off
are we
we're in the jeep at 7:22
0:28 point okay all right now
interesting to have a look back because
we always get like different numbers and
the key is well how does this number
emerge it's very close like pretty
clearly in the right ballpark so
something's going on in here right maybe
it's this possibly that's that might be
the discrepancy so this is why when you
get to an utter right one of the great
things you can do you member I showed
you on the quiz is to go through your
question right you say okay let's have a
look here have I accounted for this
number right have I accounted for this
number and I accounted for this and is
four and five right and as you mentally
check off all of the things in the
question you look at your first line of
work it should have all of them does
that make sense that's just a little way
for you